on this thursday night new york state's
gun control law struck down
the supreme court ruling triggering
anger today
is a disgraceful decision and relief my
reaction is happiness the potential
domino effects
ultimatum with the suspended national
chief of the assembly of first nations
is now threatening
seeking and destroying hidden lethal
weapons it's definitely challenging the
daunting and dangerous task of demining
ukraine and dogged determination
a clever canine's great escape from a
pet hotel
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
the issue of gun control front and
center on both sides of the canada u.s
border today the trudeau government
denying any political influence in a
mass shooting investigation we're going
to have that in a moment but first
tomorrow marks one month since the
massacre at an elementary school in
uvalde texas
it led to a reckoning in the united
states on access to guns but action
is a different thing
today the u.s supreme court came down
with a ruling that will allow for more
guns on the streets of america
jackson proskow has the details on
today's concealed handgun decision
as gun crimes surge in major u.s cities
the supreme court delivered a blow to
gun control efforts striking down one of
the few state restrictions on carrying
firearms in public arguing such laws
violate the constitutionally protected
right for americans to bear arms
shocking
absolutely shocking
that they have taken away our right to
have reasonable restrictions the court
overturned a new york law that limited
who could carry concealed weapons in a
6-3 ruling the conservative majority
agreed it was too difficult for ordinary
citizens to obtain a license to carry a
gun in public those of us who have
permits have gone through the process of
permitting
we're the most law-abiding people on the
planet we don't commit any crimes the
decision has big implications in many of
america's largest cities similar laws in
some of the most populous states are now
expected to fall we may go from a
situation where very few people carry
guns concealed to a situation where many
many people carry guns concealed and we
won't know how many people are out there
gun control advocates warned the ruling
paves the way for legal concealed
weapons to flood the streets and could
open the door to court challenges of
other gun control measures this is a
victory for bad guys with guns
and the gun industry period less than a
month after the massacre in uvalde the
high court is seemingly at odds with
this moment in the american gun debate
across the street at the capitol
lawmakers from both parties reached a
rare compromise they're set to pass the
first new gun control measures in years
but those bipartisan measures seem
unlikely to stem the tide of gun
violence in this country which claimed
more than 45 thousand lives just last
year to get consensus democrats had to
walk away from their plans to raise the
minimum age to buy an assault rifle and
they gave up on a federal red flag law
meant to keep dangerous people from
getting their hands on guns
farah jackson prosco in washington thank
you jackson
prime minister justin trudeau repeated
claims today that there was no political
interference in the investigation of
canada's worst mass shooting trudeau
says his government had a lot of
questions after the 2020 killings in
port-a-pick nova scotia but at no point
pushed for more information to be
released as a new report seemed to
suggest earlier this week but as abigail
beeman reports that hasn't stopped the
opposition from pushing for a larger
investigation
from the other side of the world the
prime minister addressed accusations of
political interference bubbling at home
we did not
put any
undue influence or pressure we continue
to have support have confidence in the
commissioner ultimately as we know
police make the determination on what
information to release and when
dominating question period whether the
government pressured the rcmp to release
information about weapons used in the
april 2020 nova scotia mass shooting to
further the liberal gun control
legislation families who lost loved ones
in the worst mass shooting in canadian
history want answers the question is
who's not telling the truth
why should canadians believe this
minister over that of a well-respected
rcmp officer the government has hit a
new low to ram through legislation so
let's take a look back at that gun
control legislation the shooting was
april 18th and 19th 2020 just 12 days
ago
those heinous acts
strengthen our resolve may 1st the
liberals announced a ban on more than 1
500 so-called assault style weapons and
minister after minister raised the
shooting their families
deserve more than thoughts and prayers
then a reporter asked why the government
was so focused on legal guns when the
shooters were illegal watch then public
safety minister bill blair read from his
notes the responsibility for for
identifying the weapons that were used
in nova scotia is with the rcmp
and and and it's a and the release of
any information pertaining to those
is theirs the type of weapons were not
publicly known at that point but blair
added this and i can say with some
confidence that the two long guns that
were involved in that investigation
without identifying them are included on
today's list the rest of us would later
learn the prime minister was briefed on
the exact weapons used april 24 before
the gun control announcement so we know
the government had the information it
wanted to underline its case for
specific measures and made a point to
connect the dots
but many questions still remain about
how the pieces fell in place
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the first desperately needed aid
shipments are starting to arrive in a
remote area of afghanistan that was hit
by a 6.1 magnitude earthquake early
wednesday morning
food and medical supplies are arriving
by helicopter to the paktika region
where most of the mud-walled buildings
were damaged or completely collapsed
when a quake hit it's estimated that
more than 1 000 people have died and at
least 1500 were injured but those
numbers are expected to climb the
international aid agencies which had
been operating in afghanistan would have
been leading the relief efforts but they
largely pulled out of the country last
year when the taliban retook control
ukraine received a morale boost off the
battlefield today despite russia making
more gains in the donbass
european union leaders voted unanimously
to approve ukraine's bid to become a
candidate member off the block ukraine's
president volodomir zielinski says it's
a unique and historical moment for his
country but as redmond shannon reports
achieving full membership could take
years
ukraine is now formally facing west
cemented as an official candidate for
european union membership
along with moldova and a provisional
candidacy for georgia there can be no
better sign of hope for the citizens
of ukraine moldova and georgia in these
troubled times
president vladimir zelinsky called it a
victory for ukraine he set the process
in motion just days into the war
triggered by russia's invasion
but eight years ago the dynamic was the
other way around
then it was ukraine's european ambitions
that preceded russia's first invasion
vladimir putin capitalizing on the
political chaos following kiev's
pro-european euromaidan protests
annexing crimea and backing pro-russian
rebels in the donbass achieving eu
membership and its potential economic
benefits will take years and just one
member state can veto progress as
albania and others know only too well
let's say the truth
bulgaria is a disgrace
but it's not simply bulgaria
the reason is the crooked spirit of the
enlargement
is totally crooked spirits ukraine will
also need to continue reforms of its
justice system and on corruption
progress on that may even be helped by
russia's invasion a war that has
increased pro-european sentiment across
most of ukraine's political spectrum
let's put it bluntly i mean you're
crying for ukraine to survive as a
democratic as an independent state you
know it has to really align with the
european union so that is the only
solution or the only hope for the
country and russia knows that russia
also knows the eu's push to the east is
similar to nato's potential enlargement
with finland and sweden formally
applying last month but ukraine could
change the eu fundamentally it would be
the largest country in the block by area
but it would have one of its poorest
economies redmond shannon global news
london
and prime minister justin trudeau is in
rwanda today and visited the kigali
genocide memorial as the first official
stop on his 10-day international trip
our chief political correspondent david
aiken is traveling with the pm and as he
reports with this visit trudeau is
trying to signal that the african
continent remains a foreign policy
priority for his government
[Music]
the kigali genocide memorial a special
and somber place what happened
here in rwanda 28 years ago
resonates not only
every day for rwandans but resonates
around the world as well
as something that we all have to be
vigilant on it was a canadian general of
course romeo delaire who was in command
of the united nations mission to rwanda
in the spring of 1994 when the genocide
against the minority tutsis was
perpetrated as many as 800 000 people
are believed to have died in that
genocide more than 250 000 are buried at
this memorial all the world countries
who could have intervened
made mistakes
and in so doing refused to give me the
resources i needed to prevent let alone
stop it one of the legacies of the
rwanda genocide was a re-thinking of how
the world responds to such atrocities
atrocities now seen in ukraine where
russian soldiers are accused of acts of
genocide against ukrainians i think
strategically
there are still some significant lessons
to be learned in regards to
the protection of human beings
the establishment of human rights
and also the assessment of what
is our self-interest prime minister
justin trudeau's memorial visit kicked
off three days of events here where he
is trying to show african leaders that
the continent continues to be a foreign
policy priority of his government here
in kigali the trudeau government
announced it would establish a full high
commission in rwanda and assign a
permanent representative to the african
union in canada we'll provide the united
nations world food program with an
additional 250 million dollars to help
counter food insecurity in africa the
trudeau says is caused by the russian
invasion of ukraine that will make a
real difference right now but of course
there's more to do
russia is responsible for the global
food crisis we're facing right now
trudeau wants to hammer home the message
that russia is hurting africa when he
has face-to-face meetings with
commonwealth leaders here friday farah
david aiken in rwanda's capital thank
you david
the world health organization is
deciding whether to declare monkey pox a
global health emergency the who convened
its emergency committee today to
consider the declaration it's the
organization's highest level of alert so
it means the un health agency considers
the outbreak an extraordinary event that
would potentially require a coordinated
international response now many
scientists doubt the declaration would
make a difference since developed
nations with recorded cases are already
moving to shut it down
monkey pox has sickened people for
decades in central and west africa to
date more than 1 000 monkey pox cases
have been reported in non-endemic
countries and so far no deaths
the pope's canadian visit confirmed
coming up where his trip will be and his
first stop
despite ongoing mobility issues pope
francis will make his long-awaited visit
to canada this summer where he plans to
further apologize for the catholic
church's role in the residential school
system the vatican has released a
detailed itinerary for the pontiff's
five-day tour which begins in edmonton
on july 24th the pope will visit the
site of a former residential school in
alberta will meet with survivors and
celebrate mass at commonwealth stadium
he will then travel to quebec city to
meet prime minister justin trudeau and
governor general mary simon before
making a final stop in iqaluit
national chief of the assembly of first
nations roseanne archibald says her
suspension is unlawful unless it's
lifted she's going to take legal action
archibald issuing a statement online
saying regional chiefs on the afn
executive committee do not have the
power to suspend a national chief and
that the only way to remove a national
chief is for the confederacy of nations
to call a special assembly for that
purpose archibald was suspended last
week after complaints of bullying were
made against her allegations she denies
the federal government is moving closer
to creating a national council to
monitor the progress of indigenous
reconciliation in canada crown
indigenous relations minister mark
miller tabled bill c-29 which would
establish an independent nonpartisan
group to report annually on the progress
being made toward reconciliation the
council will be made up of at least
two-thirds indigenous members and was a
direct recommendation of the 2015 truth
and reconciliation commission the
liberal government included more than
120 million dollars for it in the 2019
budget
hockey canada says it needs to do more
to build a safer culture in the sport
the statement follows the federal
government's move to freeze public
funding in response to its handling of
an alleged sexual assault and out of
court settlement it says hockey canada
is deeply committed and actively working
to foster a culture in our sport where
everyone involved feels safe and of
which all canadians can feel proud
ottawa says taxpayer money will be
restored once hockey canada discloses
recommendations made by a third party
law firm hired to investigate the
alleged incident involving eight players
four years ago
a dramatic rescue to show you tonight
this is from the swimming world
championships
american artistic swimmer anita alvarez
fainted while performing her solo free
routine on wednesday now her coach
andrea fuentes quickly jumped in the
water to rescue the two-time olympian
alvarez was given medical attention
beside the pool before being taken away
on a stretcher
i do remember like the very last arm i
did
um
i gave like it's such a simple small arm
but i was like give everything until the
very end and i did that and then i
remember going down and just being like
kind of like oh like i don't feel too
great and that's literally the last
thing i remember actually
despite the frightening incident alvarez
says she can't wait to get back in the
pool
ukraine's mind hunter is ahead the vast
and deadly consequences if volunteers
miss a spot
it's one of the most dangerous jobs
imaginable finding and disarming the
thousands of land mines now littering
ukraine jeff semple met with one team
working to demine parts of the country a
process that's expected to take decades
to complete
on the outskirts of the ukrainian
capital the cleanup has barely begun
in neighborhoods once controlled by
russian forces residents are returning
to pick up the pieces but lurking in the
rubble a lingering danger
after four months of war ukraine is
littered with landmines bombs and other
explosives remnants of russian rockets
along with booby traps deliberately set
this area was was all russian positions
this british army veteran is part of a
team of foreign volunteers working
alongside ukrainian police to safely
remove and destroy unexploded ordnance
and they've got their work cut out and
this is just a small fraction of what
they've recovered so far quite a wide
range of explosive devices brought here
to this secret warehouse from anti-tank
mines to mortar shells to missiles
85 000 pieces recovered the team has
found explosives hidden in homes
playgrounds cemeteries even underwater
some like these cluster submunitions are
so sensitive even a change in
temperature can trigger an explosion a
lot of civilians they'll if they find
artillery shells or something in the
house they'll move them put them inside
the road they do that with submunition
and they're detonating because they're
just so volatile dozens of ukrainian
civilians have already been killed most
are agricultural workers like vadim
sridhinko
i drove past here a couple of days ago
and i was fine he says but the second
time through his truck hit an anti-tank
mine incredibly he escaped with minor
injuries this area was marked as
dangerous but farmers are now forced to
risk their lives or their livelihoods
the agricultural companies that rent
lease the land here are under huge
pressure to generate food
and that's that's basically driving them
so people are taking risks the
non-profit group the halo trust has been
demining ukraine since 2014 after
russian-backed separatists first
attacked the east the team had just
finished clearing the city of mariupol
when russia invaded it's definitely
challenging especially when the conflict
is still ongoing the halo trust is one
of few organizations willing to operate
in an active war zone and they recently
received two million dollars from the
canadian government canada was the first
country the first new donor to respond
to our call it will be a challenge it
will continue to be a challenge for many
many years for ukraine officials
estimate that 300 000 square kilometers
will need to be cleared an area the size
of newfoundland and labrador that grows
larger as the war drags on
experts predict it will take not years
but decades before these neighborhoods
are finally safe
jeff semple global news
next a homesick hounds navigational feat
that left his owners scratching their
heads
once a year the winner of the
westminster dog show prances their way
into the hearts of the public but those
prize-winning pups are being
overshadowed this year by a dog from
kansas and no it's not toto mike drollet
reports
they're also prim and proper at the
westminster dog show for media it's
low-hanging
fruit
for days they run their odd little runs
onto every newscast but hold your chew
toy this year they're losing screen time
to a mutt from kansas
this is dexter the loving family pet of
jeremy and sarah henson
well a few months ago the hensons went
to las vegas dexter was sent to a dog
hotel
on the third day
the henson's video doorbell alerted them
to a visitor
dexter hi buddy
good boy stay there
sit as it turns out dexter had escaped
his hotel by jumping over a two meter
fence before running three kilometers
home
what a smart boy though good boy so how
did dexter who is safe and sound find
his way
while a recent study out of the czech
republic hooked up cameras and gps
tractors to a bunch of dogs and let them
run
and while 60 percent use their powerful
noses to retrace their route home what
amazed researchers was that a third of
the dogs would first orient themselves
along a strict north-south axis before
taking a new path home
so they now believe dogs are somehow
capable of using the earth's magnetic
field for navigation
pretty cool huh oh
hello sweeties look there's no denying
the cuteness or practicality of these
so-called ambassadors calming air
travelers at the kelowna airport the
bloodhound
and a bloodhound winning best in show at
westminster is certainly newsworthy good
boy here comes some lights but this week
a mutt named dexter is stealing the show
mike drew high global news toronto
and that's it for global national for
this thursday night i'm farah nasser on
behalf of our whole crew thanks so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your canada is lake louise
in banff national park alberta until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
each other